she turned this bestselling tour into a
movie and the movie has held the number
one spot at the box office for the
second weekend it surged well over a
$100 million it's made history is the
first concert film ever to cross the
$100 million
Mark why why I don't am i g to have to
go see this movie am I gonna have I
avoided the Taylor Swift errow tour I
might have to go see it to make sense of
this cultural phenomenon because I have
an
inkling of why Taylor Swift does so well
I don't mean to diminish Taylor Swift
she has a lot of things to recommend her
is she Bach is she Mozart no I don't
think so is she the greatest Lyricist or
musician or singer or dancer ever no is
she the most glamorous Hollywood star
ever no is she no and actually I think
that's why she's so popular she's just
kind of normal